ministre alors que le président de la
république a récemment évoqué les
problèmes que pose le communautarisme et
le séparatiste islamiste sans indiquer
comment ils comptent les combattre
d'ailleurs une adolescente de 16 ans
fait face quasiment seul à une vague de
haine et de violence sans précédent et
n'est plus scolarisé en effet pour le
seul crime d'avoir critiqué une religion
l'islam
après avoir été harcelée sur les réseaux
sociaux la jeune miley est aujourd'hui
victime de ce qui peut être comparé une
fatwa conforté par la prise de position
honteuse et inadmissibles du délégué
général du cfcm
la violence qui s'expriment contre
millas nous rappelle en effet les fatwa
lancée contre salman rushdie charlie
hebdo et tous ceux qui en ont la liberté
en critiquer l'islam entre les insultes
islam et entre les insultes homophobes
et les menaces de mort 1001 est devenu
en quelques jours le symbole de la
volonté des islamistes d'anéantir notre
liberté d'opinion et d'expression et de
réinstaurer le délit de blasphème en
france il n'y a pas de racisme dans le
fait de critiquer une religion quelle
qu'elle soit
l'islam comme toutes les autres
religions doit se soumettre à la
critique à l'humour et aux lois de la
république monsieur le premier ministre
en voulant s'appuyer sur une association
l'amif dans lequel les frères musulmans
sont très présents et re met
systématiquement en cause notre liberté
de conscience et d'expression
le président de la république parvient à
tri à imposer à certains musulmans qui
ne veulent pas l'entendre
notre droit de critiquer toutes les
religions
[Applaudissements]